I have this tweet from James O'Keefe
this video was uh was pretty shocking to
watch there have been reports about
buses that have been trafficking illegal
immigrants in fact I can say this as
well I have personally confirmed the
existence of major airline boarding
passes that state no name given this was
bro this story was broken uh by Ashley
stclair it uh we're still waiting on on
vetting and development so by all means
anyone in the Press who wants to doubt
this story you feel free to do so but I
will put my reputation on the line and
say I have reviewed the materal IAL it's
more than just a boarding pass saying no
name given we've had our own employees
at timcast W uh witness on these flights
doing these events Planes full of
illegal immigrants carrying these bags
with instructions they don't speak
English someone is doing this and it may
be uh uh not just we we know the Biden
Administration has been facilitating uh
much of this we know this because back
in 2021 there was a report about migrant
children illegal immigrant children
being smuggled on flights in the in the
in the late hours at the early hours of
the morning into places like Tennessee
in Westchester and uh we we from those
stories and from the expansion of them
we also so we know that exists we also
know that yes Greg Abbott and other
Governors have been sending illegal
immigrants deeper into the country in
various places the question is why is
this happening why isn't there why isn't
our border being secured why is it that
when James O'Keefe in this and this
video is is it's it's crazy they follow
a bus carrying these illegal immigrants
the bus tries to hit them the bus tries
fleeing and swerving through the road
going on and off exits trying to lose
them because journalists are following
them and then actually stops and does
not release its passengers and then
leaves again something about what
they're doing has them scared someone
will find out they're doing it but I'll
give you one quick story that happened
to me personally outside of this you
know Ashley stclair uh uh showed me the
materials it's a boarding pass that says
no name given do you want to board a a
major airliner with people our security
rtsa has no idea who these people people
are where they come from I was in
Chicago over the holiday we flew on a
private jet how about that it's really
fun isn't it and our shuttle bus driver
said the other day a 737 came in and we
were told by our bosses that it was the
Blackhawks how fun does that oh you're
going to you're going to get to go
service a plane pull out the luggage for
a famous hockey team he said when they
pulled up to the plane and opened it up
there were three garbage bags in the
forward uh uh in the Ford cargo hold
that's it no luggage nothing they then
found out that the entire plane 140
pound passengers were illegal immigrants
and he said it was Swift air I don't
know that's what he told me I asked him
did they lie to you claiming it was the
Blackhawks because you would not have
served that plane had you known you'd be
facilitating illegal immigration and he
went Bingo exactly so my question now is
with all of this news breaking and this
is a massive story I'm interested in
your view on what's going on I want to
know how you plan to handle it what you
would do and I also want to know your
position on how do we handle the fact
that there are federal federal law
enforcement officers actually
facilitating this yeah well I think it's
again one of these when it was comes to
the media third rail issues when you
name what's going on so forget the
labels great replacement Theory whatever
just forget the labels what's going on
is what's the most parsimonious
explanation is there is a facilitation
of mass illegal migration into the
United States to secure lasting
electoral majorities for the Democratic
Party MH and the reason you know that's
not a conspiracy theory is it is a
pre-stated strategy of Democrats dating
back to about 10 years ago and it's not
a surprise when you got mayorca sitting
by Joe Biden side about 10 years ago the
guy who's actually running the
Department of Homeland Security right
now who is in turn refusing to enforce
the remain in Mexico policies yes that's
exactly what's going on and hiding in
plain sight and the math makes sense it
works so now you have AOC coming in for
cover in recent days what this was
yesterday or the day before saying that
actually the right solution isn't
building the wall but to document the
undocumented which is the next step to
them participating in those elections
and so it's if somebody tells you this
is what I'd like to do then they take
actions consistent with achieving what
they'd like to do and then consummate it
by actually doing that very thing in
changing the composition of the
electorate and translating into who
actually ends up voting in elections you
tend to believe that that's the most
parsimonious explanation not something
else that we're otherwise struggling to
figure out how to solve well once we
figure out how to solve that we realize
it's not a technical problem right and
sometimes what bothers me in a lot of
the Border discussions is people get
into some sort of and I I've done this
too I'll get into technical details you
know do we any aquatic barriers in the
Rio Grand what do we think about the
airlines how should they be conforming
the standards to the other people that
the TSA the Thousand standing around as
I call them at the airport or or what
are they doing none of that
matters actually eliminate the intention
get the intentions in the right place
they are intention is for people who
enter this country illegally to not be
in this country technically becomes
actually a very easy challenge to solve
militarize the southern border we're
militarizing other people's borders how
about militarizing our own with our own
military militarize our border as we are
doing and should not be doing for others
use the Aquatic barriers in the r Grand
stop giving money to Central America
most of the people coming through Mexico
80% of them didn't start in Mexico
required each of those countries to
build a b border barricade all the way
from Venezuela to the southern border of
Texas and Birthright citizenship for
kids of illegals the 14th Amendment does
not apply to the kids of illegals I can
go to the legal argument on this they
duped Donald Trump on this one they said
you need a constitutional amendment
actually you don't stop Federal funding
for Sanctuary cities we're paying for
this our federal taxpayer money is
actually paying for this facilitation of
the domestic transfer to Sanctuary
cities and then anybody in this country
should be returned to their country of
origin if you're here illegally it's
that that simple now they say there's
only 6,000 ice agents immigrations and
Customs Enforcement
agents well again if you read the law
there's a section of the the law I think
it's
287g or something like this that that
allows ice agents to serve their
warrants via local law enforcement you
just need again somebody running ideally
the entire executive branch of president
who tells the department of Home
Homeland Security and Ice to use that
authority to work with local law
enforcement now you got a million people
not just 6,000 to get the job done so I
gave you all of this as though the
technical challenge was really the
challenge it's not it's a challenge of
intention right now there's been a
long-standing intention to fundamentally
change the composition of the US
electorate if you call that a great
replacement Theory CNN will CN will have
a uh conniption if you say that you know
what this is part of an electoral
strategy they would ask you what's so
wrong with that but either way we got at
least air what it actually is to be able
to have a debate whether this is
desirable policy or not but if you say
if you like it and if you support uh
people coming in and replacing the local
population you of course get promoted by
the corporate media there's there's
there's crazy stats out there they're
talking about how there's more illegals
brought into the United States than
actual babies born inside of this
country this is to me the weaponization
of human trafficking the introduction of
the third world into the United States
that's going to create a super elitist
Uber class and a poor poverty everyone
else class this is far beyond just even
a great replacement this is this is
essentially the destruction of this
country from within how can we roll This
back how can we go back from hundreds of
thousands of people coming into this
country in such a weaponized millions of
people y well you can draft them into
the military I mean what to Ukraine cu
the idea of Mass deportations is like a
storybook Nazi Germany Vis like I can
see the images of like newly deputized
ice agents like a 19-year-old cop going
and like grabbing some woman and pulling
her out of her house and her screaming
as the baby's lying on the ground like
the world will not tolerate it even our
own country as much as I'm not saying
that deportations are are off the table
but that's the imagery that would be
swung with something like that so what
you do send send them into the army go
let them earn their citizenship by
fighting in the Ukraine I don't know
what the plan is the only thing I would
say about that is one is I do favor in
substance doing this as humanely and
respectfully as possible in substance
largely because for many of these people
it it's not necessarily their fault
right if you're sitting in Honduras or
wherever and you got a US president and
entire apparatus that's giving you a
wink and a nod to come on over who knows
maybe if many of us were in their shoes
we would have done the same thing
especially we parents of children who
want better lives for our children so I
just think it's the right thing to do
for this country because we're a nation
founded on the rule of law that's not
something that's necessarily hostile to
most of those millions are not otherwise
innately bad people but these are PE
regardless of whether they're good
people or bad people We're a nation
founded on the rule of law so I can't
with my level of sort of moral Clarity
on this I can't be a father of two sons
in the White House tell them they have
to follow the rules when I'm leading a
US government that actively isn't
following its own rules and so I think
as respectfully and humanely as possible
we have to return them to their country
of origin but there's a philosophical
Point here too which is I think once we
fall into the Trap As Leaders of trying
to make decisions based on how we fear
they will be
portrayed then we're done making the
right decisions and we're just down the
road of actually dancing to what we
think we're going to be portrayed as and
it becomes circular whereas I think the
job of a good leader
is to do what is right and when the
public does not agree with you to
persuade them of the fact that that was
still the right thing to do I I do think
the public are now very aware of the
problem that's happening right now I'm I
am totally comfortable with mass
deportations I could definitely stomach
watching Mass deportations happen I mean
we've been forced to stomach watching it
happen the other way I don't know if I'm
broken on the inside but I mean reading
these stories about people that you know
can't afford groceries and yet are
having to watch buses and schools
emailing them saying hey don't come in
today because we've decided to give the
school that you've been funding for
years with your tax dollars to illegal
immigrants so they could sleep I feel
bad for those people you know what I
mean I feel bad for the American people
that are looking at the are suffering at
the gas pump supping suffering at the
grocery stores and constantly being told
by the left that you need to feel bad
for someone else somewhere more than you
feel bad for yourself I think it's time
for Americans to get a little bit more
selfish in that regard and stop and I I
I I think they will do I think we're
we're in enough now that people are
going to yeah you got to militarize the
Border there should be I mean this is I
don't hear this enough in the rhetoric
but there should be machine gun nests
pointing outward away from our borders
saying and but then what you need is a
leader at the top that's not waving
people in because if they're waving
people in no no no Machine Gun Nest
that's not we're not going to do that
but if I I think that unless you tell
them to stop coming and I mean you do it
with more than just your words that it's
not the problem isn't going to I I I I
appreciate what I would describe as
Ian's big ask and now we're going to
walk way back from machine gun nests On
the Border to like maybe a
fence it's not even that you status
authoritarian it's it's it's more about
not incentivizing this from from
happening I mean giving our resource
giving our tax dollars is is essentially
telling a lot of people because I
covered this situation on the ground in
Mexico I covered it in Europe in in
southern um Italy as well I I I covered
it all over the world and all these
people are told hey come on in we're
going to take care of you we're going to
give you all the opportunities we're
going to give you everything you want
but they don't tell them how a
essentially a lot of multinational
corporations use them as slave labor
they don't tell them about a larger coch
brother plan that we used to have uh
members of the Senate to talk about
specifically from Vermont that no longer
bring it up as a key issue as of course
it is affecting everyone it is affecting
the blue collar middle class Americans
and even more importantly the poorest
people in this country that are now left
out literally in the cold it is a lie
when they say that these are jobs
Americans don't want and we saw this
when Donald Trump I I think the number
was around 600 or so individuals
deported from meat processing plants in
the South and then once several hundred
people are are are deported these
companies say we need to hire so they
they have a job fair who shows up
Americans and there are interviews and
you can Google and watch these videos
one man has asked why are you coming to
work at this plan you these are jobs
that Americans don't want he goes are
you kidding pays 14 bucks an hour that's
more money than I'm making right now
it's a good job for me they they want
you to believe nobody wants these jobs
as they give them away and drop the
prices and I got to say it is these
large multinational corporations that
know they can pay people under the table
dirt wages and this is how they this how
this how they get cheap labor I I just
want to say one thing to Ian's point
from
earlier I I think it's important to
understand what's going on like on the
ground in the southern border have have
any of you guys been to the southern I
should I have because actually you have
so I think that that probably affects
your view Candace it definitely affects
mine having been there it's not like you
have this situation where illegal
migrants or whatever are trying to cross
the Rio Grand sneak across get a Sprint
and then do you shoot them or not it's
not one of those
situations it's
organized by our own government it's
facilit it's actually what was striking
about it is there's a lot of things in
life that are pretty disorganized like
starting a startup company is pretty
disorganized you guys you guys maybe
have a similar Enterprise here that you
started from a ground floor I've seen
you know a lot of things that are good
in life are disorganized this is not
disorganized this is striking because of
how markedly organized it actually is
there's a process they give you forms
here's the Box you check you don't have
to know English they'll just tell you
which box to check seeking Asylum do you
have to show proof of political
persecution to get Asylum not at all
it's just a procedure you go through you
know exactly go from point A to point B
to point C and so part of militarizing
the Southern border is the signal that
we send because that's the signal we're
sending right now not only coming in but
then you show up to Sanctuary City you
get you get baby formula you get sneaker
$7,000 per migrant per month converting
Southshore High School in the south side
of Chicago into an encampment for
migrants so I think part of what we're
doing is offering a clear statement we
end Federal funding for Sanctuary cities
you know in advance that if your child
is born in the United States they're not
going to actually enjoy citizenship oh
there's a there's a wall and a fence and
people wearing camo because they serve
in the US military facing outward I'll
never have the military carrying out
domestic law enforcement functions but
facing outward against what currently is
an organized Invasion into our country
that's I think what's going on and so
this idea of yeah guys with guns and do
you shoot or not it's just like just
it's just not even close to what's
happening right now and I think part of
this is goes back to it's not the
technicals that matter it's a statement
of intention if we believe and we have a
national consensus and I believe we
basically do but the Democratic party
needs to align and admit it openly that
we do not want large numbers of illegal
people entering this country we
absolutely and quickly can put an end to
it as a technical matter the problem is
there's a statement of intention that
not only is that not with the much of
the Democratic party believes that same
Wing actually believes that is
inherently a good thing and the question
is how do you adopt policies that
facilitating it while pretending like
you actually wish for the opposite
that's really what this is about so all
the Technical Solutions become really
details footnotes compared to really a
debate about the intentions do you want
a mass change in the composition of the
US electorate and the composition of the
ethnic and and linguistic background of
people in the United States or don't you
that's what's on the table when it comes
to like uh using the law you said
earlier to you want to stick with the
law like focus on the law and really as
the president that is like your job as
the commander of the the military number
one but like Law and Order I get but
sometimes Law and Order can be used for
evil I agree and and we need to be
diligent or at least judicious about how
we Implement I don't know if you want to
call it prosecutorial or commandor uh
you
know expression you get to pick and
choose when you enforce when you enforce
the law so like deportations I I I'm
still my jury's out on this one right
now it was for me for a while too but I
think only I feel nothing thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net